my name is Lisa labraccio I'm 32 years
old I am an animation director at Ted
Edie I've always wanted to do animation
so it just at whatever point but in high
school when they tell you to start
looking at colleges and what you might
wear you might want to go and what you
might want to do I was very tunnel
vision this is the thing that I'm going
to do so I eventually decided to go to
the School of Visual Arts which is here
in New York as well and I chose that
school because they had a very specific
focus on traditional animation which for
whatever reason is the thing that I
really was sure I wanted to do so not 3d
not computer-generated animation but
hand-drawn traditional cel animation so
I started school for that and was in my
first year of school worked as an intern
on on a an animated film a feature
animated film that was a really cool
project for me because he was still
shooting that film on film and animating
it on cell even though a lot of places
had moved on he hadn't taken to digital
yet so I kind of got this opportunity to
work on animation in a truly old-school
way I was painting cells for him and
that was totally free internship that I
you know I wasn't paid I just went went
don't like three days a week during the
summer I commuted to New York to work on
that project I started in animation in
the independent animation world which is
the low end of that working on
documentary stuff and short films
festival films projects ads when they
come in but all you know that's that's
the lower end of it I work as as an
animation director and as an animator
there so I actually work with that
educator to id8
so to make that that lesson into that
script into a video as an animation
director what will happen is that I will
get a script early on in the process and
from there it's my job to research all
of the information in that script as I'm
trying to of course it's been
fact-checked when it's come to me
already so I'm not doing research in the
typical sense but more in a visual sense
so I'll look at other artists work for
inspiration
spend some time on Pinterest I'll be
reading up a lot of extra information
about the topic looking at all the
different theories and and communicating
with the educator quite a bit to ask
questions and get more information and
then from there I start to put together
a style board or a look and feel for the
project so I'll start to decide what
method of animation I'll use because I
work in traditional animation so I do
stop-motion hand-drawn a lot of tactile
elements as well and then I'll start to
create characters and storyboards and
and at that point decide if I need other
people on board with me to help me
execute the project as animation
directors at ted-ed we get creative
freedom so we do get to decide what
style and what way to execute the
project we get to do each time which is
a major perk that said if anything that
we're doing is not in service of the
information so it's very important that
we're creating an overall educational
film for what I do as an animation
director and especially working on
educational material it's important to
be really strong with visual
storytelling and some of that is
something that just comes from having
watched a lot of content and some of its
from having made the content worked
under directors who made great decisions
that you watched and sometimes terrible
decisions that you watched so that way
you can learn from that but I would say
that's the number one important skill is
that visual storytelling which comes
with a sense of like what's best to have
on screen to tell this story